my whole lifestyle is save that money
uh that's my catchphrase that's the
slogan of my show
uh i max out my 401k every year
i used to have a roth ira when i used to
qualify us to contribute to that
i've saved i've invested index funds
mutual funds
and then i've taken 10 of my portfolio
and i've put it into
certain crypto uh certain businesses
certain
you know riskier strategies so let's
talk about
asset allocation and both so you're not
necessarily recommending dude go all in
on dogecoin 100
you're basically saying look i have my
401k i have my fallback plan
i have my retirement accounts and then
i'll take a certain percentage of my
portfolio
and go for the moon did i sum that up
yeah i mean absolutely you'll know
better than everyone that the risk and
reward go hand in hand so if you want to
make a lot of money you have to be
willing to lose a lot of money
yeah take whatever you you can afford
sorry
take whatever you need for the long term
for your planning the responsible
approach to it and you have that kind of
strategy and then
you have money left over or feel like
taking a little bit more risk then you
can throw it towards
the dogecoins or whatever you know the
these lottery tickets that can make a
lot of money and
i i see this as a double component
that's kind of cool
the first one is yeah let's take a bet
and let's hope that we make more money
and let's hope that make a lot of money
and we're prepared to lose
whatever we put into the bet which is a
hundred percent uh but on the other
on the other side a lot of people once
they've placed that bet
you'll notice that they decide to read
up on whatever the heck they just invest
rather than doing it the other way
around yeah it's like so what is this
tesla thing about right or what is this
oh okay well they're announcing the
quarterly earnings and that we okay i'm
gonna have to watch that what is it
quarterly earnings
oh okay they're announcing you know
discounted cash flows and sales and
projections or whatever
the next thing you know they're looking
at the fed interest rate decision
because that affects it whatever they're
doing
and then next year they're getting
themselves educated on this and they try
to buy stock options which is a whole
other
beast right they start to learn about
that they're very complicated i mean
they can be simple but they can also be
really complicated so
that encourages people and it empowers
people to really take control over
everything and perhaps they could take
some of that knowledge they learned and
probably you know more people lose money
than they do make it we're not gonna
those statistics are out there but they
can take some of that knowledge and put
it towards
a responsible one which is okay well
i've seen the tendencies it seems like
tech is really outpacing the other stuff
maybe with my 401k i'm gonna change from
the snp
and put some more towards the nasdaq
which you know and and make adjustments
there based off of
their experience that they learn so you
know i think there's benefits to
outside of just the making or losing
money